thanks a lot and welcome I'm going to
scroll away from this but I'm going back
to it in a minute so no worries um this
is me I'm from Germany this is my
Twitter handle in Germany it's very
funny but in English obviously not the
slides are there but they are not
important I've just five slides and then
we will switch over to the to the to the
notebook this is about convolutional
neural networks like networks that work
on images and we're using tensor flow
and then chaos as a front entity and
their temple flow okay what is the
challenge of today and we are trying to
recognize speed limit signs and this is
not like rocket science because luxury
cars I don't want but at least German
luxury cars have been able to do this
for at least 10 years and this is how
they look like just download from
somewhere a pretty reasonable size of
speed limit signs and they have very bad
quality as you can see who knows what is
this hundredth rider well yeah ok it's a
hundred sometimes it's not even easy
fast to recognize them but this is the
training with you
we have limited number of samples so yes
79 of those 81 of them so this is very
limited especially for for the for the
endeavor of of training image
recognition but the only as detailed
views so all of these speed limit signs
there in the centre of the picture and
this is important because otherwise we
wouldn't be able to do this ok it's
inspired by a blog post by buddy
Abdullah and she did all the coding for
pepper for preparation so I more or less
took over a lot of the code that
actually made this those those images
processable in the first place so big
big thanks to valid and also
kudos them for doing great work so my
stuff is based on it so first of all it
might be surprising but there's no
information necessary you could follow
along using your mobile phone if it's
alpha okay so it works on my pixel I
tried it this morning or yesterday but
it's actually not recommended it's not
advisable but it's possible and and what
we do we host the notebook on our
notebooks which is surprised provided by
Microsoft and I don't know why but they
like you run very powerful notebooks on
their service for free I don't know why
but it's a nice gesture so there's no
local installation required it is
possible to do a local installation but
it's totally not advisable because at
least compared to my machine with this
notebook hosted on Microsoft services at
least 10 times faster than my local
machine I don't know how they do it but
they do it so this brings us again to
this step and who wants to follow along
by really actually executing out the
code like half it do it with this thing
right do what what what's said here do
what set on this slide and while you do
it and I also heard that it actually
works if you follow these instructions
actually works while you do it this is
the only thing that they actually have
to type in and then you do certain steps
while you do it so it doesn't get boring
I will show some code already but first
if you did this on your local machine
running on battery
it wouldn't work I mean the battery
would be drained at half an hour
it is very computation intensive thing
that we're doing so don't do it on your
local machine do this for the people who
are not like installing right now a bit
bored as I said I will do some
entertaining stuff in a minute but
and first I won't make sure that
everyone has typed in those linked you
clone right so well I could do it I
could do it wait I could do it together
with you let me see how I will do it but
I will so I'm just pretending that I'm
totally new so this is what you do this
is what you see this is the notebook
view this is this is the way you see it
when you're not logged in because now
I'm also not logged in then you click on
the workspace you can already see the
notebook but you cannot execute the
steps this is something that's also
possible on github
that's not something very fancy but what
you can do now is you click on the clone
thing here and when you do this and
force you have to do some steps because
I now want to know who you are you now
have to log in and zooming in a little
bit so the Wi-Fi is exceptional I mean
big kudos to Bloomberg obviously you do
something like unless you have a
Microsoft account any Microsoft account
escape to click on create new Microsoft
account and then unfortunately you have
used like ten of my email addresses
already to to try this out and
differently different scenarios I think
I have one left so you do this at Apache
org
I have no idea something I'll be sure to
uncheck this right you don't want
promotion and it's totally fear of
course Oh what do you this that's tough
that's the hardest thing right to find a
password that actually works the idea
for me I can't remember now so click
Next and then what they do they email
you a code and then you enter the code
and then you're good to go
it might take a minute or two let's see
if my emails already been delivered
let's see
oops maybe it's in the spam folder no
it's not
but from now on I mean I would just
pretend it worked for me it might take a
minute or so it's all very like private
and should be read by you but most of
the stuff is is in German so I'm safe I
think I'm sorry oh it's credit card not
good I'll go over here for this is it so
sorry
Promotions part okay okay did it who's
still waiting for the confirmation code
no one who with any problems that's
impossible no one has any problems the
only one with problems is me okay then
I'm blown away by this I've never
experienced anything like this so it
doesn't work for me it works for you
good better than the other way around
okay now the setup actually worked in
ten minutes
it's I'm blown away so if you don't want
to follow along on your own machine
that's also cool I will show each step
we don't need this just some some simple
guidelines for the notebooks that's the
only side our notebooks it's composed of
steps and the step is either markup or
code you can edit all the steps it's
like really cold and you type enter to
edit it you can have code completion
typing tap I will show it in an example
prefix your code with an exclamation
mark makes it a shell command so this is
a unique system running underneath and
you can do whatever you want you
shouldn't do certain things but you can
do everything long as Shift + Enter
execute 117 jumps to the next one it's
shifting and execute one step and
creates a new empty step after
so that's all you need and I will while
I type I will explain what I do okay
this is just a set of links that's all
basically I read so my background is I'm
a programmer and it took me a long time
to actually dive through all the all the
very very interesting but also very
frustrating world of convolution
networks and I hope to save you some
time by showing you and then sharing
experience okay
now I'm switching to the net in a
notebook and this is the notebook that
you have opened you should recognize it
hopefully I'm finding it okay to screw
up if it is it large enough is it okay
can you read it good hands up who can't
read it you can't read it leave it okay
I know it takes a while until actually
zooms in I don't know but it should be
it's working oh there you go
good I don't think I can make it any
bigger because otherwise I I don't know
what I'm doing anymore
so what we do first is that we install
all the dependencies that we need and
what we also do is we pre-process the
data so what I'm doing now I go into one
of those lines I hit shift and then
enter and what it does it executes the
commands right um it should look the
same on your machine this was just text
and this is the work this works very
fast on my machine on my netbook but it
should be slow on yours this is
installing scikit-learn
who does who does not know psych eval no
one does not know executor okay perfect
so this is just to help a thing to split
tests from training data
we rarely use it but just a little bit
this is just a helper for me to see if
everything's fine I'm checking the
versions here and the scikit-learn
version should be at least or point 18.1
I'm sure why doesn't work for me maybe
doesn't like me and just to let you know
when there's an asterisk here star then
the step is is executing at that time
and you need to wait this is executing
right now it should be very fast
operation so I'm wondering why but
because it went so smoothly before I'm
not mad at all not not yet so maybe it
actually worked it didn't tell me it's
also sometimes the case well you do the
same thing right you score full cool the
stuff you try to install all the stuff
step after step maybe I was too fast at
one point I don't know
just one trick when you have the
impression that the account sort of
doesn't like you anymore than you do
reconnect you shouldn't do restart
because then you lose all the state of
here of your notebook so don't do this
just use restart so it doesn't work for
me
I will it seems it doesn't sorry oh it
does oh I was too impatient sorry I am
impatient so the next thing that we're
installing and this is the main thing
this is called tensorflow
intensive flow it's a very low level
like library and all you can do is you
define tencel's and the tensor is
something like a higher dimensional
array so it ends up of one dimension
would be an array of two would be matrix
or three would be something like hard to
imagine four or five and so on and it
can actually execute operations on that
and those operations are typically very
expensive to compute but we don't care
because tensorflow does it for us and it
also can make it run on a GPU and I
suspect that the that the max of people
actually executes all that stuff on the
GPU because it's so fast
however tensorflow is is very powerful
but it is very tedious to you so you
don't want to work on the level of
tensors you don't want to at least I
don't want to understand what the tensor
is I had to but why I want to do machine
learning because of this what we do we
install a second library that sits on
top of tensorflow it's called chaos the
chaos gives us high-level ap is where we
define nets where we define optimization
strategies and this is what this is the
level that I'm confident with that I'm
that I think that's cool for me so chaos
I did install and they recently released
version 2 and I prepared all that using
version 1.2 but it seems that's all just
cool so version 2 seems to do just the
same stuff as
welcome one it also tells you a lot
about wrong models and it's very very
helpful I would never use tensorflow
without chaos when I do machine learning
and again reference to the great article
that that I took some of the code to
pre-process the images from great stuff
just big fun okay
so first step we need to understand the
challenge like how hard is it and we
need to prepare the data I have data
somewhere and I'm downloading it right
now that's possible on other notebooks
and that though there are links how to
do it I just use curl here Carl is
something that that works on Linux use
users users normal HTTP stuff and I
download the data from here it's there
it works
next thing I'm dipping it because it's
tip file this is all boring this is just
preparation on machine learning and I've
a look at it now gets more interesting i
unzipped it and you see there are five
directories and each directory has a
number and that number is the label I
set it up like this so you find some
some images in here there and they are
there and the directory names surface
labels and I scribed it in the readme
okay
oh that was bad stuff no it works I was
afraid I was navigating away so in
Germany there's actually 30 km/h and I
think you have 20 miles right so this is
German and assigned then we have 50 we
have 70 80 100 120 and as you know
beyond that on German Autobahn you can
go as fast as you want so there no old
speed limit signs be beyond that this is
already quite fast but it doesn't matter
so I have images and how do they look
like this is again still preparation
they look like this they're the PPM
format which is to be obscured to me
I've never heard of it
anyone heard of ppm image forward
what what is it I mean why sorry I would
ask you binary well it took me a long
time to actually find anything that
could open it that there was italic
sorry I don't know but what actually can
work on it is it's a socket image so
good stuff so what we are doing there
preparing stuff this code you just
ignored I just copied it from from the
other guys from the lead and it helps us
loading that stuff and now that's
interesting we have the labels in here
and the image is in there and what we
have we have our six labels you see it
here I think I need more space now I'm
getting annoyed because better okay what
you see here you have six labels and we
have not even 400 images that is toughy
because typically training on image data
that's my experience and that was about
other people tell me you need a lot of
data but we don't you don't have a lot
of data so let's see let's see how they
look like already saw that in the slides
that's how they look like and as you can
see we have different amount of labels
for each of those categories for this we
just at 41 for this year 81 for the 50
so it's also not evenly spread and also
they're not normalized so some has this
shape 39 by 38 and there are three
colour channels and also their
intensities like how they are spread
it's also not normalized but that's very
bad for trading because this gives us
variation where actually there is not I
mean there's no difference between
something of this resolution of this so
what we do we actually normalize this
and this is where psychic image
comes into play and Sackett image has a
transform function and sorry transform
object and you can use the resize
function and we resize all of them to 64
and that's also mandatory because when
we feed this in into a neural networks
they all need to have the same size
because we have to specify the amount of
of nodes that they are feeding in so now
we if all the images in 64 x 64 and
three colour channels and all the values
and the color changes are between 0 & 1
so they are normalized now this is also
like very technical preparation and
still not machine learning but mandatory
we have to do it ok
oh by the way is there any questions do
not hesitate just to ask you can also
post it in the in that channel but then
I don't see it until later ok so if your
questions just ask so now we'll be using
is numpy and you probably know it it's
it's the basic library that provides us
with data structures those data
structures are shared all over the area
of machine 1 and what we're doing is we
transform the labels which is 1 2 3 4 5
and the images we transform them into
nampeya rays and it's it's common to
name the labels with a lowercase Y and
the and the the training material um
with the uppercase X and the shape I
think that's pretty obvious
there are 379 labels and we have
matching to those 3 not 79 labels we
have arrays of 64 x 64 x 3 this is this
so this is how our data structures look
like so the first and probably the
hardest if the only hard part I'm not
sure is
choosing the right architecture this is
this is super hard it's it's also not a
soft thing they just whoops or you just
Google and then oh not good we just
Google and then eventually you find the
right solution because everything is
different well what do we do so first of
all some technical stuff we a not good
it should work
I mean technical difficulties I think
would work eventually so I'm not worried
so first what we have to do we have to
turn our labels into categorical stuff
that is just technical we have to do it
otherwise it doesn't work
so and if you look into into into this
thing it would look you may make sense
out of it but it's not worth it so just
don't try it so what we starting with
and this is quite good that it doesn't
work right now because you see it's
still executing this very very very
simple step it shouldn't take a second
but that doesn't matter because we just
go through it because I wouldn't execute
this anyway so because well I'm not good
at explaining this otherwise it doesn't
work that's that's a bad explanation
right so so the how it looks right now
it's just the number like 1 2 3 or 5 or
0 and now it turns it into an array
where each of those well if it actually
executes I could show how the new data
structure looks like it executes it
converts it into an array of arrays in
each of those areas there are a bunch of
zeros and one and that one like
represents the real category
it's just technical thing to make it
work
that they make it make it any smarter
right now it's yes it's probabilities
but all the probabilities are 0 except
one and this one is 1 so it's just a
technical thing unfortunately well
doesn't like me anymore
let's oh it does like me so we can
actually do it so it looks like this
right
as I said for each of the categories we
now that used to be one right this used
to be zero this used to be zero also
zero zero zero so it's turned into this
data structure just for technical
reasons it's boring but we have to do it
and there are a lot of things in between
so don't think this is all just ones and
zeroes though a lot of things in between
and it used to look like just an area of
numbers okay so now works again good but
we still don't execute this because it
takes a lot of time even on Asia and it
doesn't help us so don't execute it and
unless the part that I'm actually
actually explicitly telling you to
execute so first what we do we create a
single layer your network and this is
how it looks like so this is just
technical stuff imports this is not
technically really a layer but no yellow
we're technically it works like like a
layer neural network but it's not it's
just defining how the input looks like
and you already know 64 times 64 images
with three colour channels one for red
when one for blue one for green and now
we take this and put it into a fully
connected there who does not know what a
fully connected layers okay oh I had no
idea oh okay good then f6 explained it
right
so this works as an input it's a layer
that means well I'm not very good at
drawing you will see it but I will do my
very best
so this is one image another one another
one they're all 64 sorry actually bad at
drawing at this thing here times 64
times 3 because there are three color
changes right now you feed it into
something there is one layer they can
actually accept that stuff and now what
that input layer has it has 64 times 64
times 3 input nodes
some people get bored I see this but I
have to do it and now it feeds it into
the next layer those are neural networks
and we have 4 layers in them and the
next layer it actually has 226 nodes
56 sorry 256 nodes and I can't draw them
for these reasons right but I'm drawing
like few of them and how this works is
that each of those input nodes gets
connected to all of those improvements
and that's why it's called fully
connected or dense so that means this
thing gets connected to this this also
that this thing you see what I'm doing
it's probably boring right so and then
next thing that means you get a lot of
connections and this is the input the
first layer this is a so-called hidden
layer and then once we've done that I
connected all of them - all of them we
also have a final layer and the stuff in
between we just ignore for now and this
is the prediction layer and it has 6
neurons this time I might be able to no
I'm not four five less and fix one and
now each of those
notes in this way I connect to those
output nodes and they have so called
softmax activation that means what they
actually output is a probability that
should I think should add up to one
if if this the input like the this thing
here to what category corresponds so say
I feed in a 30 give me a second I'm just
finishing this so I'm feeding in the 30
and it should like give a probability of
say 1.9 here this would be 0 this 0 in
this 0
maybe there's the 1.0.1 somewhere the
question I'm sorry
perfect so so the question is how did I
shall find out about these numbers those
are obvious right
this is just not how my input looks like
this is just guessing this is just
widely guessing just taking something
and telling you secret it doesn't work
at all so this this I have something
that works no words but this doesn't
work at all and this is business this is
not only me I've been told that this is
the life of the most people who do this
you try things out you read literature
you try it you do an experiment I will
show the experiment and then you see it
won't work and this doesn't work either
so this is the very bad number this is
very bad architecture but it is a very
simple architecture now for the 6 the 6
is very important because I have six
categories so this is my input and I
want to map it to the output to the six
categories wanted feed in 30 and that
now I want to get some something like a
probability of how probable or how
likely is it that this actually is the
30 and this is because the 6 is fixed so
the 6 is a good idea this is a good idea
everything is in between is a very bad
idea but it's simple
so all the other things that we're
trying a little bit later but very
similarly have to apologize for my bad
drawing but don't get any better so what
we are
oh wait I forgot something right no I
didn't forget anything so this is again
just just syntax or technical
requirement for for chaos you create a
model and the model it represents the
architecture of our network and you get
this input string and you get this as
the output and the model is defined you
can see the input shape which method
matches this you can see the output
shape which matches this and this is the
only thing that will not change when we
make our model better okay don't execute
this
this thing I actually don't know is it
the batch size ah good point good point
bad size so we will in s in a minute
well I'm actually executing this now so
in a minute we will actually use this to
train and you're right then we will
actually see that that they're feeding
in batches of data
good point Thanks but first before we do
this we have to compile the model and
this can be compiled to either
tensorflow
or or see anything help me piano piano
is the other one so Candice can actually
interface different backends and we are
using tensorflow here but I think the
default is Tiano so that means you
define a model and you can make it run
on tensorflow in the same modeling make
it run or something else so I have to
compile it to this and this is just the
lost function that's very mathematical I
don't understand any of the details of
it to be honest and it's tricky so I
read a lot of what the sense of people
write and it always gives me the
impression I'm not smart enough to
understand it so maybe you do I don't
but you have to set it like this is the
right thing to set because it's
categorical we measure on accuracy like
accuracy accuracy ethic to see how well
have you trained we could also measure
on loss but we're measuring on accuracy
then there's optimizers and this thing
here rmsprop I always use the SGD but
people keep telling me this is the best
thing no one knows why it hasn't been
scientifically published but everyone to
give selim you have to use it and it's
impossible for me to understand it like
never it's a very simple mathematical
thing but I still don't get it and as I
speak to very smart people I get the
impression they don't get it either but
maybe that that's me it's just for my
experience it's just like trying out a
lot of things and see what works best
like like a very I know engineering
approach I'm not quite sure if you agree
but if anyone actually understands it
then talk to me later
so these other standard optimization
things I always use this because I was
done I had no idea but this is actually
the right thing to do and this is just a
way to tell you like to visualize that's
the best that I could find how they they
try to this is the settle here and you
want to find the minimum how the
different optimization strategies how
they proceed from this and this is very
bad because they have no idea that they
should go down here this is way too fast
and this always looks like it's best
so it's slowly and very decisions me
goes down here why is that important
because we want actually when we try to
train a model we actually want to have
very good results and it should actually
find the minimum so it's always about
minimizing the error in in the network
and this seems to be the most promising
thing and there's a second yeah well
looking at this this is obviously not
good they are slower and it looks like
well maybe maybe it is also good right
depending on what so it's if you look at
it if you want to want to go in the
direction of the minimum and you want to
be very good at it well right you don't
see it here maybe you see it on the next
visualization but you can see it it's
better than then
create a decent right because we
indecent sucks and the green one also is
very bad because it takes a while until
files are to go down this is also very
bad maybe maybe one of those is the best
because these days they very quickly go
in the right direction yeah
oh it's it's just something this is just
made-up function that you're trying to
optimize to try to find the minimum
it's just something it would be like
like the like pivoting this would be
two-dimensional because that when you
just have two parameters would be s like
thousands of parameter and each of these
things would be a parameter for for a
neural network now we are trying to
minimize like the loss of that network
and this is it like the height of this
settle is like the overall loss of this
thing so you want to find the minimum
yes
yes so it's just generic right so this
is this is just generic stuff yes right
so ADA Delta gives the fastest but it
might be too fast yes right so this is
just a generic why am i showing you this
because this is the best explanation
that I found on the net so showing you
the mathematical formula it's very small
very simple but for the incomprehensible
at least for me this also is the second
good realization also generic and it
shows this is supposed to be the
actually actual minimum this is supposed
to be gradient in all that thing and
this is just a visualization how they
are they actually find that minimum so
we could also argue that this is better
or the black or blue one but is always
in these three and as I said people have
much more practically experiencing use
this and you're on the same side on the
safe side so hopefully that wasn't too
confusing let's see
so maybe that was too much detail I'm
not sure but what do we actually do so
to find out if the architecture actually
sufficient but people do that are
smarter than me they do some sort of
sanity check they use a very small
fraction of the training data like 5% or
something that's what I'm also doing I
think I'm executing this because of
brave today and now oops wrong my coat
that's not good
well does it work for anyone else yeah
obviously I messed up by my no papito so
no worries because the results should
still be okay so what we see we now have
approximately 5% of 400 that means 20
and what we're doing now we try to
overfit a model which means we try to
get 100% accuracy
that means we're trying to use the
architecture to actually perfectly fit
our training examples which are just
1820 in our case if this doesn't work we
can be very sure that our architecture
oh no not very sure it's it's a strong
indicator that our architecture is not
sufficient to actually solve the whole
thing and it might take a while even
whenever that's why I'm not doing it and
I can tell you it's stuck on accuracy it
doesn't move at all
it's very low accuracy you could argue
and you never know that if I just keep
on training keep on training it will
eventually have an high accuracy but I
doubt it
so first what we do is something new
here so yes the model I pass in are they
explain as well sorry a thousand some
training data and are part of training
labels this is the batch size like how
many of them do you feed in at once and
it's subtle how big it should be some
people say if you'd make it too small
you tend to over fit if you if you make
very large you needle of memory so it
should be somewhere again something you
try out I have 300 values and I've
fitted in the batches of 100 and I'm
training 450 a pox howdy-howdy Brown
said English epochs that means I do this
same thing 50 times over and over again
same thing 50 times
and here you see one of those epochs
this is 93 and you see this is the loss
that means the overall error that is
lipid abstract and the accuracies it's
much easier to understand how many of
them do you actually train correctly if
you check them that means just 20% of
network and it's stuck at that value so
not good
fully accurate would be one and this
should be totally possible this is just
20 of them this is just it should be
totally possible to accurately represent
them it should be one right and it's not
and it's arguably maybe it's just
because I didn't like try enough but
most likely it's not so it's just not a
good architecture and this comes back to
the question that we had a bit earlier
how did I come to this 226 I was just
guessing but what I'm doing now if I
make my network stronger by putting in
more than 1000 and theoretically which
you can read here also something the
proof I don't have seen at all but what
the proof says I understand it tells us
that it's possible with just one hidden
layer to represent any function that
means theoretically if you make this
large enough and you actually get it to
Train behave the way you want one single
layer one single fully connected layer
is always sufficient practically it
doesn't work at all but theoretically it
could it doesn't work at all and this is
also very very hard and it goes over my
head but it's it's it's a matter of how
do you train the whole thing and you
just can't but not with the with the
mechanisms that you have so I did this
this time I'm not letting it run no the
other time also didn't let it run
because
hidden layer oh I think I put it before
but I will show it again so in the
network the first layer it's well the
network its composite layer is the input
layer it's a draw drew before right you
feed in the images 64 times 64 times
three colour channels and then you have
the output layer this was the six
categories you remember yes one two
three six and in between there may be
something
and typically in between you have many
more layers and those layers are called
hidden layers so we have just one layer
in between it's fully connected that
means all the inputs go to all these
nodes and this is called hidden layer
it's just one and as I said
mathematically it's provable that one is
enough theoretically but it's in
practice no so this also doesn't work so
I made a bigger
I made a higher choice it doesn't work
and it's not as desperate as the one
before so I see improvements with the
one before we were stuck at 22% and I
will start at 28% which is also very bad
it's totally not sufficient they see I'm
not cheating on you and I tried it for
100
a pox what people tend to do and what
turn out to be a good idea and practice
is add more layers one in layer second
layer you split you split the numbers of
neurons to those two layers and then we
have to William layers I mean I think
it's obvious now but we're still drawing
it now input layer output layer one
hidden layer two in layers and there was
still fully connected it means all of
those input into all of these so if a
lot of connections you have a big model
and
how much time do I have by the way
one-wayness is over oh that's great so
by the way if it's boring anything or
you want to do something else and tell
me
but if plenty of time and I'm very very
happy about that
oh right so I used flatten before I'm
not actually sure if it's if I have to
do it here but what it does is typically
well we would have to wait that's a very
good question because it's it concerns
the shape of the data that those flows
are through our network what is the
shape of the data are close to our
network and I was actually asking the
very same thing to myself this morning
that's why I made some experiments
traffic that is I know I didn't tell you
right to ask this question so yes so
yeah perfect yes right I actually need
it so the shape of the input if you look
at it this shape is this is things like
playing that this is the this would be I
think it's the batches but never fall
about it I always ignored this person so
the shape of this thing is 64 times 64
times 3 this is the shape of the input
and it gets more complicated there but
what I need to fit in into the last
layer is one dimensional so what I do is
I create this three dimensional or I
take the three dimensional cube and then
I just flat it so it's just I don't know
it's flat well it's it's just sorry
yeah the vector perfect it yes exactly
this would be a three dimensional array
or matrix I don't know and I need to
have a vector and that's what sin does
so it's just again a technical thing and
I need to have it here right because
what comes in is
wait right what comes in from here it's
something like a super three-dimensional
matrix and I need vector to fit this in
into this into this last dense thing
here needs edit okay
training training results is the
pointing you see it might have worked
but they did not so still bad it could
have worked on some days I mean it's
it's always then I'm telling you it's
not deterministic this thing depending
on on this on the start initialization
of my network to be traded some times
works and sometimes it doesn't sometimes
this works sometimes with the two layers
I get actually get 100% accuracy it
could have worked yes
what is the great here - Eugene argue
argue chooses can I just take the PDB
randomize them and America just
ultimately it was his controller for the
convergence of being how you factor the
beat oh you are the question if I get it
correct how do I flatten the data and if
it's at all just do it just just any
random way and then what follows of
course needs to be correct training for
this deterministic flattening how we
flattened it doesn't matter how we do
later that that matters so we don't know
how we said this I don't know yeah yes
yeah oh wait possible so the question is
that's the way I flatten the whole thing
influence the result that's possible but
so it's not something that we influence
and I don't expect to be big differences
I think the flattening thing you just do
it and then later in the next layer we
we just have to like match the way we
flatten it so the next layers is the
thing that that actually is to be smart
may be thought of announcer I'm quite
sure so I'm confused what did I tell you
oh ah I claimed without having a proof
here is that this could have reached a
100 percent accuracy but they did not in
our example in I have somewhere I have
notebook that actually achieved it so
well so let's say we found something
they actually like achieve this then
what we would do is to check the whole
thing on the full data set so let's see
we have you found the architecture which
we have not and then we will check the
whole thing on on all the training data
wait did I do this
where did I do this sorry I'm not seeing
it
oh here here we're doing it I was lost
sorry sorry don't execute any of this
right so don't do it
so what I'm doing now I think I didn't
probably explain it before it's that I'm
splitting tests and training data in two
different fractions as before so this
time we have test data 20% and training
data 80% and you probably know but the
idea behind this is I train with 80% of
the data I tried to make the network
none and then later I test with 20% of
the data and this is just to make sure
we just didn't over fit and it just
works for the data we're feeding in but
also for the other data and that's
dispute like how you should split should
you do it like 6040 and this is also
just opinion I would say I did 20 sorry
8020 because I only have 400 data sets
to Train so I didn't dare to like
sacrifice a lot of the data for testing
so this actually takes on a 15 minutes
because the model is complex and you're
not running it it's it's a - hidden
layer model and on a good day which is
not today we could get something very
good accuracy you see that I actually
shift that one day I don't remember one
that's that's quite big this is
79% on that model and then what you can
do when you trained the whole thing you
just an evaluate function you put in the
data that you want to go yet this is the
training data so this should be really
high and the training data it has an
accuracy of 96% which is really good
that means like 96 percent of that of
the data is good but then as I said you
split between training and test data and
then have feet in the test data
now the accuracy goes down to 71% do you
think that's a good result that's how to
say right I mean how could you but then
let's say you're driving in your
maecenas and it tells you you're on the
50 zone but you're in 30 zone that's not
good right 70 percent it's not good it's
not good even saying that that our test
set was very small and then the overall
training set was also very small this is
still not a good result you can do much
much much much better so we're doing it
now and I think I have to speed up but I
don't know how now we're getting to the
much more interesting part so we've know
all the basics we prepared everything
there for more than half an hour left
which is good and now we're coming to
convolutional neural networks and we'll
have to scroll up and they look like
this you have many many many layers like
the classical ones if many layers you
can fit in something I stole the image
that's why it's not well the speed limit
sign you give many layers those are all
in layers and at the end you again have
a fully connected layer that does the
prediction and again it has in this case
one two three four it has five
categories this is the most the thing
with the most lightning and horse is
unlikely same thing but this time you
have many many more layers and s you
maybe you didn't experience but I told
you if I took in two layers it took me
15 minutes to train one more layer
probably an hour but this thing uses
some tricks to actually make it possible
to have that many layers and use
different kind of layers it's also
different before we just saw fully
connected if convolution is I will
explain them you have the stress
activation we can ignore your putting
layers and you have them stacked one
after the other if time permits I will
show you two other like setups of those
convolutional neural networks but this
is just different architecture it but
technically it's again the same thing as
you saw before
I will show you this time are you
totally invited to execute the code as
you see we are now importing new kinds
of layers let me see if I can still
execute I can't good good for me we have
input same thing but now what not
happens now is you take the input this
is the input this is something like
that's pretty broad like well however
you would describe the shape and you
slowly turn it into something that is of
this shape that means you're reducing
the dimension of your input but you have
like a lot of outputs from that that's
very abstract at least at the idea and
also like the abstract ideas longer this
gets and the narrower it gets the more
semantic information it carries this is
all about technical thing like this is
re image and gets more abstract and more
abstract more abstract and this is very
hard to understand
and even looking at the mathematics it
doesn't help at all so what I did again
stole an example what is this dog right
dog so if this is your your input and
you feed it through convolutional layers
what it does at the first step the first
collusion layer is this it could be this
when you see the color is gone like all
the three colour changes they are merged
into one color is not important for it
and is not at the at the level that that
we use it as humans so merges all three
layers of that dark into the one but now
it applies I don't obviously forty which
is unlikely maybe a cut off some of them
would be more likely than 60 16 it
creates 16 or 14 representations of that
dog that a much more abstract but you
still can see the dog because what it
does on a technical level is it applies
the filter kernel something that you
might know from
I know Photoshop or something why you be
apply filtering operation to an image
and the parameters of their tutoring
transformation of the caramel that's to
be learned by the network and if you're
familiar with image processing some of
this which may be this they look like a
sharpening operation some don't like the
blur operation which is how to image
because this is already very blurred and
what operations are performed on that
image it's learned by the network and on
deeper layers this is just the first
layer this gets much more abstract you
don't see anything anymore you can see
like how the pixels are distributed and
that might mean something but on deeper
layers it's just like in representation
that you no longer like intuitively King
can't grasp so this is just the first
day maybe I mean the filter operation
how it works it's surprisingly hard to
envision eyes it I could simplify it by
lying and I will do that for you let's
say you have an image with just I don't
know each of those cells is a pixel and
now you go over it with with the filter
let me change the color here you go over
it with theta and the filter typically
has a kernel size which in this case is
two by two which is not uncommon and
what you do is you like for example add
each of those pixel values by a certain
amount and then divide it by something
else
I don't know possible that would be like
a filter kernel that if you do this if
you add them all up and then we divide
them by four well what kind of image
operation would this be I don't know
it's it's is it blurry is it some people
are nodding so that would be an
operation that's still be feasible and
to be learned by the new network that
would be doable
and then once it done this so it created
a new value here up here you value once
it done this it moves it over by
straight value which could be one but
mostly is is two again
so you move to this one then you perform
an operation on this and you create the
next next Pixley this is just like image
processing but the the interesting part
it like how this is process is
completely learned by the network how
does this look like it looks like this
so whoops sorry this would be the first
block of of convolutional layers we have
three after each other
so this is already three hidden layers
right a lot and you have 4x4 kernels I
was drawing the two by two coordinates
for before and the stride like how far
you move it with each step is also far
and this outputs 64 by 64 because it's
still the same size because the input
was 64 by 6 before but this time we were
applying 33 filter configuration so the
the tensor that gets output is 64 by 64
by 32 so something that's led like this
they made like very wide it used to be
free but now it's 32 that's what we do
why we do this I don't know because
that's that's what turned out to be nice
so because it's now just deeper and we
want it like more narrow there's there's
a down sampling they in between and well
it does it takes a larger image and
makes it smaller done and the idea
behind this is to reduce data sizes and
at the same time for reasons that I'm
not fully aware of its said to reduce
overfitting so overfitting means it
works for the training data but not for
the test data and if you do this people
say it reduces overfitting
which is questionable because there are
a lot of approaches they don't use it
and they still are better so it's all
just what people what professors say in
their talks so what it does how it does
it it's it's called max pooling you
could also do average putting that this
is max pooling and how does it work very
simple you have a two by two I don't
know how you call it something two by
two bucks pudding theater and you look
at this thing here and you see the six
that's max this is the result you go
over this you see the eight bucks this
result again three max and for max and
this is if you imagine this to be an
image this is the scale down down simple
version of this image and it's called
max pooling by the way I have links to
two more detailed explanations but if
you click on them you will find that the
authors were from Stanford they explain
a very similar way so that they say why
it works we don't know we doubt it works
that's what people have been doing try
it out maybe works for you so it's not
at all settled science or something okay
here's my max pudding there 2x2 as I
said now something to reduce overfitting
again is to have a drop out that means
with each with each training batch I
drop out a certain amount of of notes
that means I don't chain them I just I
just pretend they're not there and 50%
is common but I'm using 25% because I
don't know why 50 I could have used
fifty four fifty seem to seem to be - me
so the reasoning for those sizes here
right so why is it two by two and why is
this up here give me a second why is
this 30 I wisely 32 things this is just
a quote you ever have it this is just
described here so that they're different
approaches like how do how to process
images this is an academic paper from
2014 which means it's ancient it's
totally no longer valid it's three years
old you can forget it but this is how
they describe the network here and they
they had very good experiences with it
that's why I'm doing it just like
reimplemented what they say in that
paper which is actually readable and as
I said they use drop outs as I'm doing
here they use the convolution the
filters small ones that means like we
have something like 4 by 4 2 by 2 I
don't remember there could be much
larger but that's what they are that's
what they are proposing it's quite deep
so I mean typically it's between 16 and
19 layers and you saw before two layers
were too much for us 16 to 19 again is
too much but you have something like 10
layers I'm doing it because it's
described here I will promise that I
will show two other approaches that are
both better because they are do that do
it differently so sorry drop out I
showed you technique it's what I said
you do it because you you want to
prevent overfitting and overfitting
again means it works well on your
training data but bad up data it has
never seen and then you keep on adding
blocks while you do it you get deeper so
first we are 32 now we have 64 then we
get deeper and we again down sample so
as shown as the explanation the first
image we're actually doing exactly
what's what's described up here
sorry for the scrolling so we become
deeper but also more narrow more narrow
is what the down something does keep a
is insert this is what the collusion of
layers do and this is what the down
something does like reducing the size
again why it works no one knows but this
is not like the lame excuse
it's actually the truth so um now what
do we do here again set up the model I'm
a little bit afraid to do it because it
takes time
you might start it if you want to but I
will just show with that so I'm training
what am i training here 30 no yes I'm
trying 30 epoxy and you see it has a
hard time learning but you see a lot of
movement it goes down and you might lose
trust but you should not it's still not
good after 30 a pox and then I keep on
training and training because I knew it
will be naturally work and now we have
98% of accuracy accuracy how you
pronounce x-ray see I'm German I'm sorry
good thanks and this is something that
tensorflow provides us this image thing
there's the tens of flow I forgot the
name tensor flow does anyone know the
thing that that creates this 10 support
tanks 10 support it's a 10 scible so I
use the 10 support to check how this how
the training worked and the beginning it
looks bad but then eventually it should
start off match the rmsprop way of
optimizing but well that's very hard to
see here if at all so but the accuracy
is very high
what's this is ecstasy
hmm I'm not quite sure that I get the
question so why is it going up is that
so what yeah that's a very good question
so a lot of the the set up of the
network is fixed like the dropouts
it's fixed the flattening thing is fixed
the down sampling stuff is fixed have to
saw a long way I'm sorry
but what is not fixed if the is the
parameters of the convolutional layers
like how they filter
that's not fixed at all so each of those
like parameters is a variable in a
function that we need to optimize for so
the parameters of the function that
we're trying to optimize their huge a
huge parameters much more than two I
know maybe there are thousands maybe
millions sometimes that's what we are
trying to optimize and what we are
measuring at the end is that we stick in
a picture we know the right result and
then we check how accurate is the
prediction here and we do this while
training I know some some framers they
can't do it they only show of the loss
but we can show while training assure
the accuracy and if it was one that
means each prediction is perfectly right
we're very close and you see the
evolution over time this is the overall
error which should be in the other
direction and there you see how to do it
yourself if you want now we are already
in the validation part and we should be
and I didn't train it I know will it
still work
am i pre-trained the thing but it says
the training accuracy in the end is 1
that means perfect but this is not
important or not really what I was
shooting for oh [ __ ] sorry so if you're
using bad words also but what we can
also see and this is much much more
important this is the test stuff and
this is the important value this is 90%
I had it up to 95 percent accuracy which
is very good for that size of data what
that means that is much more powerful
than the model
that that doesn't use convolutional
layers so 90% I prepared this because
obviously I messed up my notebook here
so what I'm doing I'm randomly choosing
ten samples just to make this a little
bit more I don't know impressive and
those are the predictions and if the
prediction is green it's right so the
truth for this is far the prediction is
for it obviously right and it's a little
bit boring because each of these ten
predictions I did this this morning so
to make it look good is actually right
so this is obviously it's a very good
test set because each of those it could
predict correctly and this bit is very
hard I think this is very hard for you
thirty right but all the predictions it
did right so probably you're no longer
like typing on your laptop's anymore and
you should because um it would take a
lot of time what we do now is we save
the model which care that allows us here
I'm just saving it it's just very easy
model safety there you go I can list it
and if you count correctly this is known
as this one but the same size okay this
is a 32 Meg right 32 megabyte for a
model of I mean that's not a complicated
model but it's big already so what I'm
doing for reasons I will tell you later
I upload it to this nice service
transfer Dutch Shell they gives you free
space for 14 days and it's saved from
here I did this for two other approaches
and I did this to use it to predict on
real data on real images that I either
took a photo of using my cell phone and
that is the interesting part and just
watch because executing it is is not
interesting and it's it's in the in the
it's in the same library so
it's all up there so do you lose
anything Oh spoiler sorry I'm sorry okay
so this is all just installation I did
this this morning hopefully it's still
alive
they kill them after a while so all your
data is still there but the variables
their loss it's not killed which is very
good I'm very lucky so let's have a look
at the images that I actually get from
real world they look like this give me a
second
and as you can see they're much harder
right much harder I have no idea I think
it's it's the it's the zoomed out
version of this it should be 50 where's
the other hard one it's not easy to even
see this this what is it it's a 70 what
is this and I also did something very
mean I took the picture of this this
number how do you call it
we called house mama is it house number
is there anything that's a house number
obviously it shouldn't be like
recognized as a 70 otherwise your car
things you can drive 70 here and if the
officer asks you what's wrong with you
and you say 70 are not good so I did
this I did this because I'm evil and I
want to like make it as hard as possible
then then I did something like this very
high contrast change I didn't train with
this data at all we have we have it like
tilted also not in the training data
this is impossible to see it's just
nothing it's just dirt and also if it's
not centered so all the data that we use
this is the it's the detailed view and
this is this is just an overview picture
but I wanted to make it as hard as
possible so this is this is something
somebody drew it's not even a real thing
so how many of those with the thing that
you just train how many of those do you
think it recognizes correctly that's a
fun part now how many 50 oh no no way
not 50%
I'm looking bad now it's not your fault
so we're making predictions if you want
an ego that doesn't look good
the barely fit but they do so there are
15 images and five of them we get
correct this one surprisingly this one
well this one it's debatable I mean it
predicted yes that's obviously a 70 but
it's not so that is it if the drive is
wrong I don't know and this is also
correct but you see all the things that
are not zoomed in there are not editable
it cannot detect this thing is
impossible to detect this thing also is
not a detail view another detail view
not only tell you what did he tell you
and it can't it can't detect those yes
question right so a good point I mess it
up so you say it's impossible for the
model to tell the 70 from the others I
make mistakes and I will sum them up
later yes the good point you completely
right so um let's try a different
architecture and again if you ask me why
is it like this I can only point to this
paper this is the inception model done
by Google people and the idea is to have
a non sequential model so you put in
some input and then you have so-called
is it easy to see towers maybe this like
you spread the model it's not sequential
and then eventually you merge you messed
the results and that's called in section
model and there's a pre chained
inception model by Google that does
outstanding things but I did it myself
and it's okay so this is also has a
notebook up there where you can see how
it is set up like in detail but this is
how it looks like it makes different
predicts
was very surprised that actually could
make the right prediction of this I
wasn't able to but it could and it
didn't see this as the which it
shouldn't right right that's that's
already that's already solution I'm
missing the not category I'm missing the
this is a stop sign thing I'm missing
all the the other side so totally
correct bad mistakes it should predict
something like this is not even my site
but i don't have the category and I
don't have a trait so it doesn't work
and also what I don't have trained is
it's like translation variance not in
the training date at all so it's no
surprise it doesn't work still one my
example and this is like oh I shouldn't
use swear words so I'm not doing it this
is like the hottest staff in the in the
area of convolutional networks and again
if you ask me why is it like this
I can only point to this paper but I can
show you the basic idea you still
improve the depth of this you go to like
150 layers and it's still possible to
train that many layers because you're
introducing shortcuts why this makes it
easier trainable I have no idea and I
think they also don't have any idea they
just they just saw it they just made
experience and they saw when you do like
this you fit in data in the normal
production layer then you feed it into
the next but you also bypass the whole
thing for whatever reason and then at
the end you've just merged them again
you can have much higher height much
deeper hierarchies you get much better
results it's also skipping the final
fully connected layer which we had
before which makes the model really
small but also to my very big surprise
let's see if I can see it how small
actually is
I'm sorry I need to scroll good good
question the question is why do I skip
the final three connected layout which
before was said to do translation
variance and it was mandatory to to work
at all um I don't know that's but that's
the way it is how to cope with that so
no good explanations um let's see like
how big this thing is
and and again it's it's not like making
false excuses here it's not like I don't
know but the others do it's rather like
now we all know and I especially don't
know so let's compare sizes so the the
first thing that I looked at for study
to make this thing is the inception the
tower thing the Google thing it was 400
MEK 400 and this thing here now the
residual thing that I'm showing you now
is 1 2 3 1 2 that's 2 Meg right so it's
tiny and I think it's mostly because
it's also lacking the fully connected
layer at the end but let's look at the
results so it has this simple trick it's
very deep and it it skips complete
training layers every now and then oh
and also uses something called batch
normalization which is completely the
other stone use and this is I can't
completely explain but this is a way to
evening reduce overfitting stuff and
then also make them online faster so it
doesn't use like drop out or something
but instead use batch normalization and
explained is explained here if you we
don't want to know but that's also new
so let's look at the results and
that's how they look like it has 50% so
it has 50% of accuracy more than the
others but other than that I don't see a
pattern so I couldn't explain why or
what is it see is wrong with what is his
right
I don't know but it is had seven of them
and it's the smallest model so it's a
very small model it's very accurate I
think you have ten more minutes so I'm
coming to what I messed up
so first is it readable can zoom in here
now because I didn't train in
translation invariance which is totally
bad so if you drive with your car and
then the time is somewhere and I didn't
train that it has to be sent at a long
time but this is due to because I don't
have the training data I was very lucky
to even find any training data but I
just don't have that training data
accessible it's also not robust against
background I saw that in the example the
background turns blue it could no longer
make it out assess the right side it has
false positives like the 30 address
number it's not clear against it's not
robust against unclear science my 50 up
there looked like a 30 and then well it
should have said I don't know but
there's no I don't know category this is
too low 64 times 64 this is just is not
even c64 it's just nothing it's just too
low
I don't know oh yeah right
when I was doing out you just couldn't
see anything anymore if it was distorted
like tilted to the side it still
couldn't handle it I can't answer the
questions why do different actions give
so different results I don't know I
don't know if there's someone who would
know but I doubt it I think it's a
striker but I'm not sure and even if I
did this many many many times over and
I've trained the same Soria standing in
the picks I'm sorry I trained the same
architecture over and over again and
I've got very different results on the
test data sorry yes on the test data I'm
not quite sure of this just normal but
it gave me a bad feeling so um what does
that mean if I actually want to fix it
that that is just toy of course I'm not
working for the automobile industry it's
just it's no worries you could say if
you drive your cars so I'm not doing it
I should do something because I don't
have a lot of training set
I saw people doing this you have you
have the you have the image and then you
artificially create new variations of
that image by moving things around by
changing the background color by adding
distortions and this is something I
could do and then introduce a category
that says that it's not not a speed
limit at all and even the category that
says this is not even assigned this is
just nothing this is a 70 printed on my
hand or something maybe I also have
translation variance which could be
added into the training material
Association variance means it doesn't
matter where a sinus higher resolution
which for sure will reside along a
training duration and then try other
architectures just to give you an
impression the stuff that I did it was
almost impossible to train on this
machine it's an i5 aid mech no sorry a
geek machine and it was very hard to
actually train that on on on
a cloud so people who do this with a lot
more money they used much bigger
machines they use a lot of GPUs so by
this nature I'm just restricted to how
complex I can make my architecture so
this I think this leaves us with five
minutes of questions or head start for
lunch whatever you want I don't blame
anyone if you leave now and I see people
even eight-story cool so I take
questions now yes I don't find that
terribly convincing let me explain
similar a time to recognize that
vegetation and it uses T ridiculous
resolution much less right in every
region so in a way the problem I don't
think the problem effect so I guess
probably if I would have to come up with
an industrial type of application or a
solution for this unit that comes with a
pipeline where you use something like
open CV take out the back
so the so the argument of this gentleman
is that the resolution should be fine 64
by 64 and then that to circumvent
situations like this rather zoomin be
fond and keep the same reason so the
answer is I think you're right more
questions or comments yes so the
question is how come that every time I
do it the trainee air get different
results the answers I don't know this is
this as part of the questions that I
have myself that I get different results
it's because I get different training
train models but why they are different
I can't explain I'm sorry I would love
to if you can tell me yes so the
question is the the filters that I
applied that you saw in the filtering of
the dog can you pre supply them I think
you could but that's that's not the idea
of the whole thing the idea is that the
that the neural network learns the
correct tutoring but you could I'm not
quite sure if people do it but of course
you can that they are by definition
predefined but probably random values
but you could yes
the question is is this it's always
feed-forward what I'm doing it's always
feed-forward but they also return your
networks wave loops and you also have
have have nodes that have short term
memory I think that also called
short-term memory networks and this is
something that I didn't try out but
people who did say it's better
so yes it's there and this will be in my
next steps use a different architecture
use something like this but of course I
mean it why not do this yeah so people
try it out and they get good get good
results yes so the question is if I've
played with all the other parameters
like the optimi optimizers which again
also have parameters that you can tweak
and other things and I have not and the
main reason is limited time I do this
manually I type it in I try it out and
then I get in with odd and I'll do it
again and but also know that people have
a lot of more machine power they learn
well they dead train network so no how
should I put it they do something like a
meter thing that's what you said right
you you try to learn what are the right
parameters to set up my architecture and
you you have a system that learns that
for you by trying them out and then
feeding back the error but that's just
good fault I mean what you need is a lot
of machine power but I have this thing
this I five here
and not even GPU but you need is a lot
of lot of machine power but I think
that's what people do well
yes so the question is about how do I
see mate how long it takes and end oh
yeah and how and then make promises on
how good I'm going to get I wouldn't do
this because I don't know maybe there
are other experiences but I think it's
just isn't I had no idea if this would
work at all so if I had promised this to
someone I would be under great stress
which actually did because a pro process
talked before I even tried it so it put
me on a great stress because it's not
like like a program typically I'm a
programmer so you get a task and how to
estimate but eventually you get it done
and this thing you don't know if it
works at all and then how good it would
be so I don't know it's it's more like
fiddling around no it's not even signed
I know what it is
sorry bad answer but it's the best I can
give yes
so the question is if I removed colors I
did not and but we saw in the
convolutional networks that the colors
disappeared after the first convolution
they sort of like went into the
convolution in ways that I don't know
hopefully meaningful but completely
making them black black and white I
don't know maybe that's even a good idea
to like normalize them better and take
away overfitting because I'm not
interested in colors that's a very good
point that's very very inexpensive and
that's that's a great thing to try I
should yeah good point yes maybe find a
question because you know so the
question the question that the ina said
is it advisable to use this on anything
else but images and I would say I don't
think so no I think these things are
specifically being designed to work on
images but I don't have experience maybe
people apply that to other problems but
I did not know it works do you know do
you look like you you do no no okay good
good okay thanks and then have a great
lunch and great conference
[Applause]
[Music]